while the sea Jen and East River teams
prepare to install their tidal turbines
a third team of engineers joins the mix
but they're not trying to tap the tides
they're out to harness a type of power
something could radically reshape the
global energy market the power of waves
misses technology which doesn't offer
tens or even hundreds of megawatts of
power as we get better at as it's
deployed as we get the economies of
scale as the technology is honed and
improved this is technology of gigawatts
of power the Scottish government sees an
opportunity to lead the world in ocean
power technology and Scotland's eastern
coast is ground zero for the testing of
a determined wave technology program
proponents say waves carry enough energy
to potentially power hundreds of
thousands of homes
now visionary engineer Richard Yemm has
created a device that may be able to
capture some of this power turning to
the world I think we can say that
effectively the opportunity is unlimited
the 70% of the world's surface is
covered in oceans and all oceans
generate large waves and there is power
available on any coastline facing those
the experimental device he's invented
has begun to capture the world's
imagination
it's called Palomas after a tropical sea
snake the massive contraption stretches
120 meters longer than a football field
as it bombs up and down in the waves it
converts the waves power into
electricity the module itself is if you
like the engine of the system it it
takes the motion of the large tubes and
converts it into electricity waves move
the giant cylinders causing hydraulic
rams inside to pump back and forth the
Rams motion forces high-pressure fluid
to flow through a hydraulic motor which
in turn drives an electrical generator
producing electricity
in total the Palomas can generate 750
kilowatts of power
over 20 times as much as burdens East
River turbine or about two-thirds as
much as Siegen
of all the green power ideas Columbus
may potentially have the widest
application coastal sites could have
massive farms of these machines
generating electricity
the polymers design took five years to
develop tank tests with wave simulators
determine how the machine would perform
in all kinds of weather conditions from
long wave swells to short choppy ones
later scale models were tested in the
open water to measure the machines
potential electrical output and to
determine survivability now the first
full-scale polymers prototype is nearing
the end of a crucial test phase in
turbulent seas of Scotland its inventor
Richard Yemm has to prove not only that
it can generate electricity they must
also be able to take founding the
promise is unique in that it combines
features which are very survivable is
long and thin so when big waves come
through its streamlined presents the
minimal area to these these ocean
monsters and storms but it's that same
long thin form that in in small waves is
the optimum hydrodynamic shape for
capturing power someday Yemm envisions
hole forms of polamosh units said just
beyond the view of beaches
the kind of format that we would expect
would be an array of machines sharing
more important between themselves to
create a grid of perhaps 30 50 a hundred
machines covering a couple of square
miles of the sea surface that's roughly
enough to light up a small city like
Stirling Scotland to get to that point
Yemm and his colleagues have their work
cut out for them